to the submission
topic
so a part of this interview that went
viral of this woman
was her talking about how she does
can i say this on youtube i think i can
okay i'm just gonna hope she does anal
even though she doesn't like it
because he wants it
so um the internet had a lot to say
about this part and i want to give you
guys some of the reactions from people
when they saw this so ish if you could
pull up
the next um
videos and i'll show them on my phone
men love the idea of a submissive woman
submissive per its definition is ready
to conform to the authority or will of
others
the prefix sub means under
think of subpar
submarine in short
your world is under his now there seems
to be a theme here good girls vs bad
girls a lock that can be opened with
many keys is a broken lock and if you
can't submit to a man
you're gonna die alone to my question to
men is
do you want perfect polly
a puppet a prisoner
or a partner who has no problem overtly
challenging you
king treatment
and knowing your partner's love
languages that's one thing
being submissive is a whole other thing
it's its own thing if you find yourself
abandoning your wants needs desires
to make something work
i'm here to tell you
it was never a match to begin with
all the things that submission is
submission is not
doing sexual acts just to please your
man
like
i get
wanting to try something that you've
never done before to see if you like it
but once you've established that you
don't like it
and he knows that
what kind of guy still wants to do it
what's attractive about doing something
with somebody that doesn't want to do it
that's not submission that's abuse
so um i want to get your initial
reaction so we have brittany runner
who's saying
that you're basically uh
did it sound like borderline a slave to
you guys servant yeah yeah under and
then we have
the other girl who's talking about how
it's borderline abuse
what what do you guys think starting
with you um
so if you agree to it can't be abused
because you've agreed to it regardless
um
i think that
depending on your relationship and your
dynamic
it should be something that
if it's a
is quite quite political to be honest
because some people they need those
things in their life being in submission
to a man is not abuse
in my opinion just because in your
relationship the dynamic allows that to
take place
a man's position in your relationship
allows you to be submissive
also as a woman
to reciprocate the man's position
submission is part of that and there's
nothing wrong with it for me
what bothers me is there's a problem
with saying it like what is wrong with
being submissive
there's a time and a place to be
submissive and i think because it's in a
public arena it becomes
a nitpicky
process
and i i it's like why is this even a
discussion it's very
personal
quite private
um in regards to the young lady saying i
saw the clip about the anal thing
and for me it was the lack of
understanding of basic biology that got
me with her and just because of that i
switched off so i just was like yeah
it's for whoever what do you think i'll
say originally either brittany rena
whatever her name was she went from two
extremes really she said that you don't
want a perfect polly and then she also
said on top of that someone who overtly
challenges you which are two extremely
like what we don't want either one of
those anyway so the fact of the matter
is a woman can be submissive a man can
be the leader he can consult with his
lady about a subject and by the end of
the day he and she know that he's got
the final say so he would take on
people's evidence and information to
make him help make a better decision so
in that case i like what you said i'm
going to add that to my thoughts and i'm
going to make the decision and she's
happy with the fact that he's used her
information as well so it's not that
extremity of perfect poly or
overtly sort of confronted or whatever
she said and then in terms of like the
ainu and all that some people like that
i'm not really down with that but i
don't have anything against anyone doing
what they want to do but in a sexual
sort of engagement with your partner you
have to be willing to try and satisfy
them right i mean you learn to grow
together and synergistically as i say i
like that word because when two people
come together they have that sort of
blending of energies and understanding
of each other and the better that is the
better the sex is some people might be
here i like this something like that but
i could never see it as some form of
abuse imagine if a girl doesn't want to
give you head rat she's like i don't
give head or whatever other term you
want to use for that sexual act and then
like you want it and she's saying it's
abuse because she has to do it she
doesn't have to do it number one so it
can't be abuse but like would it be a
form of um
like withholding from the man anyway and
in that case they can have negative
effects on your relationship so i think
they have to come to some sort of
agreement sexually some sort of balance
and synergy between the two people and
it's no form of abuse if you've accepted
and got down with the deed anyway
i think in the first video what
i
realized is that
she made sub um being submissive seem as
if that the woman had to
completely dislike everything in order
to please her man and that's what made
it submissive i feel like there's that
mis like understanding of a woman needs
to give up so much that she desires and
she wants and da da da da in order to
submit to her man no to submit to your
man or vice versa is just to want to put
this love and energy in to please your
your partner that doesn't mean it has to
take from your own cup and i think
that's a big misunderstanding that we
have nowadays
and when it comes to the second clip i
just i agree with everything you said
and i feel like that just nipped it in
the bud for me
okay for me for the first video i think
the
lady kind of confused the word
submissive as actually meaning slave and
the two are not the same
in a woman is something you want to do
it's nobody can come and drag you to
them and say you've got to do this and
you've got to do that women if they're
in a position where they like their man
they're comfortable with him they will
literally give themselves to a person
and that's not something you have to ask
for that's something that's innate it's
part of
an effeminate quality of a woman's
quality because you know i mean she's
met the masculine that is appealing to
her feminine nature and it the two just
complement each other naturally
and
i think she's looking at the meaning of
the word too much
it doesn't necessarily mean i mean she
was deconstructing it trying to talk
about what the
the prefix is and the rest of the word
and i'm like you're doing a bit too much
do you know i mean actually understand
what the word means as it as as what it
means to be a woman
rather than what it means to be
property or owned you're not property
but you are as a woman you do have that
innate quality that men like
so just do it have you ever noticed that
the girls always have a horror story
whenever men have a standard or whenever